well onto some health news do you have
questions about medicare enrollment
the colleague phone bank is happening
right now kendall tenney spoke with
united healthcare
about how to choose the right plan scott
normally
the medicare enrollment period is in the
fall but
if someone is just now turning 65 or
experiencing
some other qualifying event they can
enroll right now
there are over 10 000 americans turning
65
each day and they have the ability to
enroll
outside of the annual enrollment or
enrollment period
during a period of time around their
birthday and then
in addition to that when someone moves
into
a new area or has changes with their
jobs things along those lines
they may also qualify for what we call a
special
enrollment period to enroll in a
medicare plan
and then with everything happening
around covet over the past year plus
uh and certainly in recent months things
are changing but we know people have
lots of questions about their medicare
coverage
and that's why our team is here today to
help them answer those questions
and if they're looking for a plan we can
give them advice on how to find one that
meets their needs
for people looking to enroll in medicare
what resources
are there available to them to make
choosing a plan
easier there are a few things that
someone should consider
number one make sure that the plan is a
good fit for their budget
pay attention not only to the monthly
premium should there be one
but also look at any other out-of-pocket
costs that there may be including
deductibles or co-pays or coinsurance
number two make sure that your medicare
excuse me your medications are covered
number three confirm that your preferred
doctors or hospitals are available
through the network
uh and the plan that you're considering
and then finally don't
uh don't forget about um some of the
ancillary benefits that come along with
the plan
potentially dental vision and other
benefits
and then finally take advantage of the
wellness programs
people are surprised to learn that a
medicare advantage plan
offer covers benefits and programs and
resources like
free gym membership and maybe
over-the-counter services
again call eight the cali phone bank is
happening right now until
seven o'clock tonight so you have plenty
of time if you have any questions about
medicare or the enrollment process
please give us a call that number right
there on your screen
702-650-1101-702-6500